david charns a man shot and killed near
the 15 at a gas station this afternoon
happened on west oaky close to downtown
that's where we find madison kimbrough
right now with the details madison
still an active scene as you're about to
see this happened at the 7-eleven right
here on oakey boulevard from what we
know so far a man and a woman who are a
couple arrived and parked at the
7-eleven around 4 this afternoon the
girlfriend went inside of the store
while her boyfriend stayed in the car
the boyfriend then got into an
altercation with a random man that was
outside of the car that man produced a
knife and stabbed the boyfriend it's
still unclear what the argument was
about but soon after according to police
that's when the girlfriend reacted after
seeing what was going on
the female exit the store right in the
middle of this right as her boyfriend is
being stabbed she produces a firearm and
shoots the unhoused male one time
the unidentified man who was shot was
found dead on scene that man and woman
then took off in their car and left
luckily they were found by police soon
after on the freeway and have now been
taken into custody stay with us here on
8 news now for the latest information
and details in this case reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now